[Música]
y
sí
ah
y
[Música]
[Aplausos]
nací en 1938
en italia en un palacio en el palacio
piscina
en un pueblo llamado ala de trento en el
norte
tuve una infancia
varios años de mi vida en italia muy
feliz a orillas de un lago uno de los
más lindos lagos que yo conozco el lago
de garda
pero todo tiene un principio y tiene un
fin
y el final de la guerra le llegó también
a ese lugar tan hermoso
empezaron los bombarderos a venir con
sus bombas a bombardear la zona porque
había
ejército alemán a ejércitos alemanes en
retirada que volvían a alemania hacia el
norte
los aviones pasaban rasantes al lado de
nuestra casa nosotros vivíamos era la
montaña la casa el camino y el lago
en ese lago que yo nadaba que aprendí a
nadar a los años y medio
en ese lago empecé a ver cadáveres de
gente de muertos de soldados muertos
pedazos trozos de ser humano tuvimos que
refugiarnos los últimos días de la
guerra que no sabíamos cuántos iban a
hacer afortunadamente fueron siete días
en esos siete días estuvimos viviendo en
una cueva en la montaña con agua potable
y aceite de oliva en realidad fuimos
afortunados porque no todos tuvieron esa
suerte cuando terminó la guerra
italia quedó devastada
entonces mi padre tomó una decisión
cambiar la vida de vida y decidió
rumbear para un país de argentina donde
nada faltaba y era todo abundancia
llegamos una tarde con un barco carguero
el andreas christi todavía me acuerdo el
nombre y cuando llegamos
fuimos a parar a un conventillo de san
telmo
esa noche tuve un ataque de una
enfermedad desconocida para nosotros que
se llamó asma
estuve tres días y tres noches sin poder
respirar
y no había broncodilatadores en esa
época después aparecieron
los primeros años en argentina fueron
penas de penurias para mi familia y por
supuesto también para mí porque más que
nada lo que más me afectaba era no poder
ser un chico normal no poder jugar no
poder andar en bicicleta y sobre todo no
poder ir al colegio
y sin embargo
este tuve un golpe muy fuerte a pesar de
eso
un día mi padre me miró y me dijo vos
sos medio cartucho
eso fue un golpe terrible para mí
ustedes saben que en italiano a decir
medio cartucho
muy duro
sin embargo gracias a eso y gracias a un
profesor de gimnasia
que me enseñó a respirar yo pude salir
adelante
y no solo puede salir adelante vence un
montón de cosas que me parecían
imposibles todos nosotros podemos
podemos vencer cualquier cosa porque
nosotros no debemos tener nuestra mente
el pensamiento no puedo no puedo no
existe no debe existir para el inym y ni
para mí ni para ustedes y esto es lo que
quiero transmitir
eso no debe existir con esa gimnasia yo
empecé a respirar mejor pude ir al
colegio pude tener amigos tuve que
quedar libre para poder llegar a los 16
años a la facultad de ingeniería entro a
la facultad de ingeniería yo me había
ganado unos pesos
haciendo unos carteles que decían
abiertos cerrados prohibido pasar
gerencia damas caballeros
y con ese con ese aprendizaje pude
hacerme un juego de escuadras que me
compré un pedazo de material para
hacerla voy a la facultad y un compañero
me dice sí
estas escuadra donde las compraste no me
las hice yo como tela existe vos si me
las hice yo y entonces
yo empecé a pensar y dije
tengo una visión me voy al centro de
estudiante de ingeniería le muestro las
escuadras que había hecho
dice que están buenas estas escuadras
no me gusta hacer escuadra para el
centro estudiantes y claro le dije yo
y si hacemos 200
digo pero 200 escuadras voy a tardar
mucho no importa pero así me las
y entonces hice los 200 juegos escuadras
tardé dos meses
con un compañero me ayudó a hacer las
escuadras nos asociamos
alquilamos un galponcito en el fondo de
una casa que no tenía ni baño
teníamos que pagar el derecho del uso
del baño de una polaca que estaba a la
vuelta del taller citó y ahí
aprovechamos y nos comíamos un sandwich
y con una cocacola yo no porque no me
gustan las gaseosas
y yo tomaba un café con leche
me compré una bicicleta que era una
bicicleta inglesa
de tipo inglés fuertes para poder cargar
los materiales con los cuales hacer las
escuadras porque empezamos a vender las
escuadras a muchas empresas los grandes
negocios que había aquí en buenos aires
va aquí estoy en esto en córdoba también
vendo mucho aquí en córdoba ahora
pero en esa época me conformaba se me
había ido la voz
me conformaba
con vendieran los negocios que estaban
cerca en la ciudad de buenos aires
después fuimos ampliando el radio de
acción un compañero mi compañero decidió
que trabajar y vender no era negocio
porque conoció a alguien que solamente
comprando y vendiendo papas él para pero
tenía un mercedes benz entonces me quedé
solo y seguí adelante porque eso no
tenía espíritu de comprar y vender
entonces seguir trabajando
y después de él después de unos años
empecé a serme conocido no solamente en
los negocios sino sobre todo lo más
importante que es el usuario
llegué a tener el orgullo y la alegría
de decir que los profesores de colegios
industriales decían señores alumnos
compren escuadras compren esta escuadra
piccini porque esta tiene la garantía
del ángulo de los 90 grados lo cual era
cierto cada escuadra se controlaba una
por una antes de poder envasar las y
llevarlas a los negocios así fui
creciendo y a los 33 años esté aquí que
aparece un cisne negro' ustedes saben lo
que se tienen negro no lo voy a comentar
aparece un cisne negro se abre la
importación en la argentina entonces me
encuentro con un problema
había productos que entraban a la
argentina muy buenos de muy buena
presentación esos productos se vendían a
mitad del precio de mis escuadras mis
escuadras eran hechas manualmente y
estos productos en cambio estaban hechos
con una nueva tecnología que era la
tecnología de moldeo por inyección de
plásticos y yo de eso no sabía nada
absolutamente nada tuve que aprender de
cero empecé a interiorizarme con eso
y además como yo soy un tipo que tengo
mucha suerte por eso estoy vivo y estoy
acá tuve la suerte de conocer así como
el profesor de gimnasia que mencionara
respirar de conocer dos hermanos
españoles matriceros que esos hermanos
se comprometieron a hacerme todos los
moldes que yo necesitaría y en poco
tiempo en tres años llegué a completar
toda una línea de moldes para poder
tener una línea amplia de artículos para
dibujo no solamente escuadras
cuando tengo toda esa línea
también debo decir que yo me comía una
foto que la voy a presentar porque no
les mostré a ustedes la bicicleta
para adelante
este es mi primer vehículo que lo tengo
todavía en la empresa y es digamos el
leimotiv es la bicicleta y me han
regalado una bicicleta hecha con todos
los productos míos el cuadro las ruedas
todo y lo hizo una a una señora que es
un artista de aquí de córdoba
que es cliente mío el marido es cliente
mío freiber sarita breve es la que hizo
la bicicleta en miniatura bueno este
voy a seguir con el resto entonces
cuando tengo los moldes hechos
un día voy a sacar fotos porque una de
mis pasiones como escuché que dijeron y
que cierto es la fotografía iba yo con
mi cámara réflex
y estaba sacando fotos de retratos de
chicos y en un momento determinado
aparece una hermosa chica que está acá
y qué
empecé a sacar fotos y foto a foto viene
nos empezamos a hacer mucho más que
amigos dejé una novia de 9 años
me casé con ella tengo tres hijas y
ahora una hermosa nieta justo nació el
23 de julio
y yo cumplo años cumplió 80 el 24 así
que el mejor regalo de cumpleaños fue
ese bueno la conclusión es que con esa
señorita que terminó convirtiéndose en
mi compañera inseparable de viajes junto
con mi nick con perdón con mi cámara de
fotos
empezamos a viajar y recorrer las
exposiciones por ejemplo fuimos a la
feria de italia de milán y vamos a parar
los albergues de la juventud porque no
teníamos dinero para pagar un hotel pero
así empecé a conocer otros productos
otras líneas que fui agregando a la
empresa esos productos y otras esas
empresa me ayudaron a mi ampliar la
línea de ofertas de los artículos acá en
argentina
cuando en un determinado momento uno de
los tantos de la argentina- que se
cierran las importaciones nuevamente yo
los traía por marca propia de la fábrica
la única fábrica vía que en que había en
el mundo que fabrica hacía esos
artículos las plantillas y los lectora
fos hechos con una tecnología nueva
entonces cuando se cierran las
importaciones me encuentro otra vez con
el grave problema de que es lo que voy a
hacer
y entonces
me acuerdo de las palabras porque yo leí
bastante de lo que es general management
y me acordé de lo que decía peter
drucker peter drucker obviamente decía
un buen pse o convenció de una empresa
un buen buen sido tiene que dirigir la
orquesta sin partitura porque si tiene
partituras no tiene gracia y vaya que
argentina que da la oportunidad porque
no tenéis ni necesidad de escribir la
partitura porque te cambia las cosas del
día a la noche entonces aquí no hay
partitura que valga
y eso evidentemente es muy importante y
después hay otra placa también
que se las voy a decir aunque no haya
aparecido acá no importa es de philip
kotler que dice me maravilla en las
empresas las empresas que hay está me
maravilla en las empresas que hacen de
la innovación una rutina están
construyendo el futuro si uno no se
innova constante y continuamente en la
vida se muere se muere a nivel
empresario a nivel personal
uno tiene que siempre tener expectativas
para poder seguir adelante y hacer cosas
nuevas
entonces qué hago la voy a ser más breve
porque me va a faltar tiempo sí no
hice algo muy simple me puse a producir
las escuadras aquí en buenos aires logré
fabricar cosas
que se hacían únicamente en alemania y
aquí las podemos hacer en argentina
empecé a exportar a todos los países
prácticamente latinoamericanos exporte a
eeuu exporte a europa exporte a alemania
donde en alemania evidentemente era el
cuna de todos estos productos y logre
ese objetivo
en él en un determinado año de la década
de los 90 yo se me ocurrió ampliar un
poco más hacia el mundo las cosas y
entonces se me ocurrió tener una
exposición un pequeño stand en la feria
de frankfurt frankfurt es la meca de las
exposiciones de nuestro gremio
cuando llego a franco a frankfurt con el
gerente de ventas un amigo
llegamos 7-juan las banderas de todos
los expositores
es la manera
y ahí
me di cuenta que flameaba la bandera
argentina con italiano que estaba vacía
después de eso yo me encontré también
con la dificultad
esta va a crecer con unas mesas de
dibujo de ingeniería de arquitectura con
las cuales me apoderé del mercado
argentino y le vendí a las principales
empresas
las empresas de inclusión automotriz de
las constructoras porque era lo único
que tenía producto de una alta
tecnología que traía
pero otra vez aparece otro cisne negro'
de golpe pero con la imposibilidad de
importar porque se ha cerrado totalmente
modo una fábrica
en 1500 metros cuadrados
con 45 personas
y ahí
sigo trabajando y sigo pudiendo ofrecer
los productos a las grandes empresas
estoy en el mar todos los años para
poder hacer conocer los productos que no
tenían que envidiar a los productos del
mundo
pero siempre estuve viajando por todos
lados
y una de mis pasiones como tales escuché
que eligieron hicieron en la monografía
esta es una foto que yo saqué que la
titulé la madre y el niño acordarnos de
la piedad
de miguel ángel
esto resentir en la línea
yo tengo una exposición de hecha en el
centro cultural borges dónde estuvo
el embajador hindú
a inaugurar hace 4 años yo hice muchas
exposiciones
y esto es una exposición de particular
porque nadie se conforma con un metro 20
x 80 entera sobre bastidores como si
fueran
bueno en los viajes también alterne con
cosas que a mí me gustan argentinas
yo soy un fanático de los deportes
acuáticos extremos y lo reconozco porque
necesito al adrenalina por eso
esto el juego es un deporte que es
relativamente nuevo y sobre casos
enseñamos
no cobro nada tras enseñar
soy fuera tipo de bucear con tiburones
porque consideró que el único animal
peligroso somos nosotros
de los síntomas
estos son tiburones en cuba que no hacen
nada que adquieres un amigo mío y
pero mi corazón
[Música]
es música negra
a veces es mentira vallecas
la verdad
por cierto porque yo estoy acá
y eso lo saben todos
[Música]
que a la isla de guadalupe
de la costa mexicana unos 200 y pico de
kilómetros más
[Música]
de bariloche
y me habían invitado gracias antes
julieta me había invitado para hablar
con las amantes y yo siempre menciona el
chamán
entonces sería una gran disyuntiva
habíamos preparado un viaje todos la
salida a la fecha colombia lo compra el
pasaje para ir a bucear a guadalupe con
el tiburón blanco ese famoso de 5 metros
de la película del blog
pero no te olvides de la unidad yo no
puedo hacer nada
es imposible volvieron a él
entonces dejé de lado esto porque visión
quería estar
por qué
les voy a transmitir algo que es lo más
lindo que puedo decirles hola yo tengo
todo lo que quiero y no visión nada de
lo que no tiene
nada
[Aplausos]
[Música]
i
y